[Music]
December 21st good morning John it's
Friday December 21st for those of you
who have always wondered how I talk so
fast at all of my videos and so rarely
screw up any of the things that I say
it's because of these iMovie actually
has like a little scissor logo so it's
like yes this is what you're doing
verily it's like cutting and pasting
kids who are born in 15 years they won't
know what paste is they will think that
it's ctrl V I just went back and watched
that noise I just made again the funny
one anyway Johnny want to tell you
something last night I had a dream I had
a dream that I was sitting on a stage in
front of hundreds of people and I had to
play my guitar in front of all of them I
couldn't remember any of my nerdfighter
songs my guitar wasn't working and then
by the end of it I was a member of the
Violent Femmes and there was a little
girl who was going to come save all of
our lives but I didn't know any of the
chords to any of the songs John didn't
know any of the chords I was like guys
Gordon Brian remembers the Violent
Femmes I don't know how to play this
song and they were like dude it's
blistering the Sun we have played this
song at every concert we have ever
played since 1987 and you don't know the
chords and I was like no I don't I'm not
a very good guitar player it was very
scary especially cuz it was like the end
of the concert and the crowd was like
we've been sitting through all these
songs that I've never heard you play and
waiting for blister in the Sun and now
we're not gonna have it because this guy
can't play the chords it would have
sucked a lot more if it hadn't turned
out that like the world was ending and
there was this little girl who had the
power to stop at all and yeah so they
did end up not being so bad but I think
it's obvious that I have some anxiety
here however I have an announcement to
make the voting has been pretty clear my
punishment is certainly going to be
performing nerdfighter songs for at
least an hour and if I need to drink
drinking Strawberry Hill flavored citrus
wine blended with peeps which sounds
sounds like a pretty
stephannie significant punishment in
ended yes it sounds sounds like it
sounds like I'm getting what I deserve
is what I'm trying to say but I have a
second announcement to make as well I am
coming to you late today because I have
something to tell you specifically
nerdfighters who live in Missoula and I
had to get confirmation on all this
before I could announce it I call a
friend who has a friend who owns a bar
and
those of you in Missoula you may have
heard of it it's called the bat Lander
and my friend booked me for happy hour
at the bat Lander on Wednesday the day
after Christmas so on December 26th from
6:30 to 7:30 at the battle ender in
Missoula Montana I will be playing my
guitar in front of people and I would
really appreciate it if some of the
people there were nerdfighters a lot I
wouldn't I would really appreciate that
because I thought it's just going to be
really confusing the guy who wants the
bar is totally into it
he would just be playing the CD anyway
and so he's like whatever if you guys
want to do this you can have our stage
so he just said yes and now we have a
gig so I've been playing some of our
repertoire of nerdfighter songs and it
turns out that my dream is shockingly
accurate I don't know the chorus to my
songs and largely I don't know the words
to my songs either so this is
embarrassing but I probably gotta have
to play with a stand with like my music
on it because there's no way I could
memorize like enough songs to fill up an
hour of space before Wednesday and the
other crazy thing is that Thursday's the
next day that I'm gonna make a video
because Monday is Christmas Eve though
there will be a surprise for all the
nerdfighters on Christmas Eve Mondays
Christmas Eve and then Tuesday is
Christmas and then Wednesday is your day
and then Thursday will be the day where
I post my punishment and then Friday is
your day so I'm not gonna have another
video blog that isn't a punishment until
Monday and Monday is the last day for
her to Punahou
I'm kind of sad do you see that somebody
made me a nerdfighter sign thanks John I
think I'm outing some kind of accidental
crisis but I'm going to do my best to
enjoy Christmas and not practice my
guitar the whole time because I'm
freaked out about this any guys John I
will see you oh my god on Wednesday no
my god